[Musique]
le président valéry giscard d'estaing
quitté hier le pays qu'il a aimée et le
peuple qui l'a servi il part en des
temps tournante est victime à son tour
de ce mal contre lequel nous luttons et
qui a bouleversé le monde
en effet le décès de l'ancien président
valéry giscard d'estaing a été annoncée
ce soir
il reviendra au président larcher
d'organiser le match que le sénat lui
rendra est d'ores et déjà je vous
propose enfin mémoire une minute de
silence et dans ces temps difficiles où
le mal rôde et frappe dans le monde
je souhaite que la providence veille sur
la force pour son bonheur pour son bien
et pour sa grandeur il y avait un regard
qui était j'ai envie de dire assassin
cruel et comme un laser qui transperçait
et il valait mieux quand on l'approché
ou l'interroger avoir bien préparé les
conversations parce que si la question
était un peu longue
il vous devinez et on avait l'impression
qu'en même temps ils douch jugé et qui
nous mettait dans la catégorie des
imbéciles et des incultes toute sa vie
valéry giscard d'estaing aura été imité
même par les hommes politiques
contemporains marchera pas pour deux
régions
une sortie interminable beaucoup ne
retienne de lui que cette image
il a eu beau voilà l'accordéon ça
passait pas dire que c'est en voyez bien
que c'est même allé passer pas non moi
je m'en souviens très bien
le dîner avec les braves gens où ils
s'invitent réseau et les hébreux ça
passait pas c'était que les gens n'y
croyaient pas les traditions sont des
progrès qui ont réussi et de ce point de
vue là dans cette phrase vous avez tous
giscard valéry giscard d'estaing c'est
le droit à l'avortement c'est
l'abaissement de la majorité civile
c'est le divorce par consentement mutuel
c'est l'élargissement du droit de
saisine du conseil constitutionnel
et c'est la fin de la tutelle sur la
télévision publique et donc de l'eau et
rtf actions aussi de marine le pen la
présidente du rassemblement national il
fut l'artisan de nouvelles libertés
publiques est un ardent soutien du
progrès technologique en 2018 il
confessa que sa plus grande erreur
erreur fut d'instaurer le regroupement
familial
vous pensez notamment est un roman
familial nicolas dupont aignan oui mais
d'ailleurs risque s'était lui totalement
fou et honnête
beaucoup de gens y étaient favorables et
il l'a amèrement regretter je pense il
considérait que françois mitterrand et
lui était en quelque sorte dans la même
catégorie il y avait du respect entre
doyenné du respect et puis je dis
respect ils estiment ils rappelaient par
exemple que lorsqu'il a quitté l'elysée
c'est le diable c'est la dernière fois
que notre pays depuis 40 ans avait un
budget en équilibre n'y avait pas de
dette en france il a rappelé que le
niveau de chômage pour lui reprocher un
million de chômeurs serait un rêve
aujourd'hui pour l'ensemble des français
et chocs pétroliers brise la dynamique
de trois décennies de croissance le
chômage de masse fait son apparition et
vge s'empêtre dans la sphère des
diamants de bokassa des pierres
précieuses reçu en cadeau du dictateur
centrafricain
il aurait perdu 1974 si le droit de vote
avaient été à 18 ans et il a perdu en
1981 et courageusement il avait abaissé
la majorité civile donc électorale vous
n'avez pas pu vous aviez se retourne
contre soi
par pudeur valéry giscard d'estaing
ne souhaitait pas que soit organisée en
son honneur un hommage national
ses obsèques se dérouleront donc dans
l'intimité familiale
sa longévité était devenu une blague
récurrente comme sur ce compte qui
twittait depuis deux ans chaque jour sur
sa bonne santé certains s'amusaient même
pas l'imaginer candidats en 2022